WWF international and the world's
leading global conservation
organizations one of the big challenges
facing countries here in East Asia as
all over the world is how we need the
challenge of climate change and four
countries here especially for Indonesia
the country where this year's forum is
Elvis and if that comes down in
particular to meeting the challenge of
deforestation finding a way to create a
vibrant economy for nature that at the
same time protects the forest and humans
which are such an important part of its
natural heritage Indonesia is the third
largest greenhouse gas and littering the
world and that's because they become
from deforestation that's something we
have to change presence I nemesis they
are clearly on the way to make my power
to say